le dix huitième rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre sur le mal-logement vient
d'être donc publié dix millions c'est le
nombre de personnes qui sont touchées
aujourd'hui de près ou de loin par la
crise du logement en 37 % c'est le
nombre annuel de communes qui ne
respectent pas la loi sru de solidarité
urbaine encore un autre chiffre 29%
c'est l'augmentation du loyer moyen est
des logements hlm entre 2000 et 2010
voilà pour ces quelques chiffres on va
s'intéresser à présent au travail mené
sur le terrain avec nos invités sur le
plateau françois cheval et bonsoir
bonsoir également à mireille frésil vous
êtes tous les deux donc membre de snl
saint quentin est snlc solidarités
nouvelles pour le logement est forcément
cette première question
j'ai donné quelques chiffres tout à
l'heure est-ce que sur le terrain vous
le constatez également c'est une réalité
aussi à saint quentin en yvelines
oui naturellement c'est une cause c'est
une réalité moi j'ai les coups de fil
permanent à la maison de personnes qui
me demandent des logements mais nous ne
sommes pas là pour faire nous ne sommes
pas des bailleurs ordinaire donc c'est
pas si on peut pas répondre
favorablement les sassine votre travail
concrètement comment vous intervenez sur
le terrain pour répondre à ces
problématiques aujourd'hui qui sont
alors nous nous répondons à un problème
est spécifique du logement ceux du
logement passerelle c'est à dire ce sont
des logements qui sont attribués à des
personnes en grande difficulté au cours
de commissions qui sont dans lequel il
ya une liste de la préfecture donc ce
sont des personnes qui sont en grande
difficulté et qui ont un logement qu'ils
ne vont garder que peu de temps la
moyenne ces trente mois donc voilà c'est
déjà beaucoup parce qu'il y en a c'est
six mois à des associations ils les
gardent six mois nous on les accompagne
par les bénévoles et par une équipe de
travailleurs sociaux
nous les accompagnons le temps
nécessaire à ce qu'ils retrouvent un
logement durable
12le seulement logements adaptés et nous
voulons les mener vers un logement
durable avec une situation de plus en
plus compliqué pour les ménages pour les
personnes seules également à ce que
les demandes augmentent et quels profils
également on retrouve essentiellement
des femmes seules essentiellement avec
enfants avec des situations de deux
divorces des situations voilà c'est
essentiellement ce à la majorité celle
ipm seul le manque de parcours
résidentiel sein des problèmes que vous
soulevez celle des personnes dont qui
vivent dans des logements précaires et
qui aimeraient accéder à mieux qu'ils ne
peuvent pas aujourd'hui absolue un vrai
blocage au niveau des loyers des prix
alors il ya un vrai blocage au niveau
des loyers d'alger carosi si vous voulez
s'il y avait suffisamment de logements
il pourrait y avoir un parcours
existentiel qui s'organise or le
problème c'est y aller d aller logements
pour les grands prix grand prix care
ceux qui ont des grandes difficultés
mais s'il y avait des logements
suffisamment de logements ces
personnes-là pourrez accéder à des
logements autres et ça tirait vers le
haut alors oui on manque de logements
intermédiaires
l'association existe depuis 25 ans
est-ce qu'en 25 ans vous avez un petit
peu suivi des chiffres savoir combien de
personnes vous avez réussi aller à dans
les yvelines en a relogé 1100 personnes
vous savez combien de personnes vous
n'avez pas réussi parce que vous manquez
déplace aussi pour pouvoir mener votre
mission votre les médecins ne peux pas
vous dire parce que c'est la loi dalo si
la liste de la loi dalo donc départ
enquête c'est pas nous qui
comptabilisait ce qui ne passe pas on va
continuer à discuter donc du travail que
vous menez sur le terrain on va parler
également de l'appartement que vous avez
acquis 7,1 voisins le bretonneux mais
d'abord cette question que nous sommes
allez vous poser dans les rues de 50 ans
la question du jour avez vous plus de
difficultés à trouver un logement décent
aujourd'hui je pense surtout que les
rouages administratifs faut que c'est
extrêmement difficile de savoir qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour faire avancer
les choses
des faits que tout augmente et bandol
l'immobilier il est un niveau assez
et ça fait que les gens ils ont du mal à
solo j ai bien sûr c'est surtout une
question de prix quoi c'est vraiment ça
devient nous en ayant des deux salaires
corrects déjà oui on trouve que c'est
dur est fait je m'inquiète sur les gens
qui ont des salaires surtout au smic
c'est vraiment je pense que c'est devenu
impossible au loyer eau l appât du gain
de certains je crois que de jouer aux
étudiants par dégueuli et qu'ils ont
vraiment déplorable longuement il y en a
beaucoup que je loue et c'est déjà ça
l'humour même oui et je vais même pas
conformes pour pour être logés et coûte
très cher j'aimerais tout de même votre
réaction sur la situation actuelle on
l'a entendue dans ce micro trottoir les
gens sont bien conscients des
difficultés c'est vrai que quand on
parle donc de plus en plus mais à saint
quentin en yvelines aussi parce qu'on a
souvent l'impression que ça concerne les
grandes villes paris par exemple
non mais je crois que tu pourrais nous
parler des subventions d'aidé des
logements justement qui ont des
difficultés à être conformes aux normes
oui les gens dont on s'occupe sont des
gens qui sont effectivement je dirais en
bas vraiment à la limite dans les
logements insalubres dont parlait la
personne et donc
nous ce qu'on fait c'est que on crée du
logement social et ensuite on s'occupe
des personnes qui vont être logés dans
ce logement de manière à les accompagner
pour retrouver ce qu'on appelle le
parcours résidentiel classique donc
d'euros de retombées fin de retrouver un
hlm etc
donc on l'est on les accompagne beaucoup
donc les bénévoles et les travailleurs
sociaux
alors pour créer du logement social en
fait on prend du logement privé soit du
logement insalubre des logements qui
sont effectivement je dirais hors
circuit entre guillemets et on va les
réhabiliter
c'est davantage dans cette opération de
réhabilitation que se trouve notre
vocation
on l'a réhabilité ces logements de
manière à pouvoir les utiliser et avoir
des logements qu'ils soient conformes
aux normes est conforme à au moyen que
les gens peuvent mettre pour les louer
c'est à dire que non seulement ils vont
être loués à loyers très bas est
vraiment le plus bas c'est à dire que
c'est de l'ordre de 6 euros le mètre
carré dont il faudra ensuite déduire les
apl diverses subventions des deux
logements et avec des charges
extrêmement faibles donc c'est là où les
travaux qu'on va mener dans ces
logements vont être intéressants c'est à
dire ça va permettre de faire baisser
les charges qui pouvait être celle qu'on
peut normalement attendre un logement
comment est financée l'association parce
que pour faire tout ça pour acquérir
pour aussi de faire des travaux ce que
vous le travail que vous menez il faut
forcément des fonds des entraîneurs
absolument donc
d'une part l'association fait appel à
des donateurs et des donateurs privés
ont fait des campagnes de dons collecte
des collectes de dons est en fait à la
fois des collectes de dons comme font
les autres associations et on fait
beaucoup de manifestations comme le loto
nom doit peut-être parlé tout à l'heure
qu'on a fait samedi dernier et de
manière à récolter de l'argent
ensuite les opérations qui sont donc
l'achat de logements un seul enfin plus
ou moins insalubre et la réhabilitation
de ces logements
ces opérations là sont financés pour
partie par des subventions et pour
partie par des fonds propres fournis par
l'association il ya une acquisition aux
voisins le bretonneux
oui il en exemple par exemple parler de
cet exemple-là de ce dossier combien ça
a coûté que ça le foot aux travaux vous
en êtes aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez c'est une opération un
petit peu particulière parce que dans la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines n'y a
pas énormément de logements qu'ils
soient des logements vieux et qui
correspondent à ce que je vous ai décrit
mais on a donc acheté un logement dans
lequel on va faire d'énormes travaux
enfin d'énormes travaux des travaux
importants pour le remettre aux normes
est ce qu'on vise
mais qu'on ne réussira pas à obtenir
pour ce logement là c'est disons des
performances qui sont celles de des
locaux enfin des bâtiments basse
consommation voilà ce qu'ont ce qu'on
vise
ça rend la tâche encore plus difficile
toute ces normes environnementales qui
s'applique ça coûte encore plus cher
alors ça coûte plus cher au niveau des
du coût de construction des logements
neufs bien sûr mais pour les logements
de réhabilitation l'objectif c'est
effectivement d'investir dans la
construction dans la réhabilitation de
ce logement de manière à faire baisser
les charges puisque quand même le coup
enfin les charges sont celles qui
peuvent être celles d'un logement
classique dans une copropriété
donc on s'efforce de trouver des
logements dans des copropriétés où les
coûts de charges sont faibles
c'est-à-dire pas d'ascenseur pas de
parties communes particulièrement
luxueuses et compagnie mais surtout on
va faire baisser les charges relatives
aux consommations énergétiques
c'est à dire dont la production d'eau
chaude c'est à dire le chauffage
essentiel
vous étiez venu en fin de semaine
dernière pour annoncer justement ce
rendez-vous ce loto que vous avez
organisé pour récolter des fonds
toujours dans le cadre de cette
opération ça s'est bien déroulé ça c'est
pas mal déroulés on a eu plus de 130
personnes
donc c'était assez extraordinaire avec
107 préservation donc les gens se sont
donné le mot pour venir s'inscrivent et
puis on a fait une petite une petite
règle enfin j'ai été un petit peu déçu
par le résultat c'était un peu plus de
deux mille euros c'est pas énorme
on n'est plus dans des sommes à 200 à
300 connaissent ans s'est fait connaître
et c'est aussi le but de faire connaître
le travail de vous mener concrètement
quelles sont les solutions peut être
aujourd'hui à mettre en place pour aider
des associations telles que la vôtre ou
à développer ce genre d'opération que
vous menez à bien glisser et les
lourdeurs administratives sont
effrayantes ça ça nous tue l'envi ti
parce que pour obtenir les subventions
si vous voulez il faut un temps très
long quelquefois neuf mois un an
donc pendant ce temps là
le louer l'appartement n'est pas
utilisée par personne et en plus elle
elle ne peut pas toucher les loyers donc
c'est autant de choses qui sont très
lourdes
vous avez un site internet on l'a pas
mentionné mais pour ceux qui voudraient
s'y rendre pour ne serait ce que vous
aider par exemple ou en savoir plus à
votre activité à 78 et cnl 78 tous ici
point fr voilà c'est la presse qui s'est
affiché à l'écran merci donc à tous les
deux d'être venu parler de votre travail
à l'occasion notamment de la remise de
ce rapport de la fondation abbé-pierre
jour donne ce chiffre dix millions dix
millions de personnes qui sont touchées
aujourd'hui de près ou de loin par cette
crise du logement la suite du 7-8 de ce
lundi avec ce dispositif lancé par la
cpam des yvelines afin de lutter
notamment contre le diabète